[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à une ce soir trois morts en
trois jours chez les casques bleus au
mali et avec le départ des forces barkan
française c'est un élément de plus à
quelques jours du nouveau rapport de la
minustah la mission de l'onu au mali qui
va être soumis au conseil de sécurité et
que france 24 est procuré en exclusivité
les détails à suivre dans cette édition
macky sall rassuré après sa rencontre
avec vladimir poutine le président du
sénégal et en exercice de l'union
africaine est venu plaider la cause de
l'afrique menacées par une crise
alimentaire sans précédent à cause de
l'offensive russe en ukraine
et je vous emmènerai à dakar on se tient
une biennale d'exception avec une oeuvre
qui fait sensation les restes suprême
plus qu'une pièce de théâtre une pièce
muséal ou le musée n'est pas un décor
mais une mélasse elle et personnage
central grâce au talent rare du metteur
en scène rwandais dorcy rugamba
accompagné de sa comédienne principale
nathalie ibérique
deux casques bleus ont été tués vendredi
par un engin explosif près de douane za
dans le centre du mali cela porte à
trois le nombre de casques bleus tués en
trois jours ceci intervient alors qu'un
rapport
un nouveau rapport de la mini sema la
mission de l'onu au mali va être soumis
dans dix jours le 13 juin exactement au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu france 24
se les procurer et vous dévoile les
grandes lignes en exclusivité julie
photo
cette mission est parmi les plus
meurtrières pour les casques bleus et
pourtant la minus ma demande plus
d'effectifs et le renouvellement pour un
an de son mandat au mali
l'opération des nations unies cherchent
à compenser le retrait de ses alliés de
la force française barkan mais les
autorités maliennes tenterait d'entraver
le travail de la mine usma selon le
rapport dévoilé en exclusivité par
france 24
par exemple la zone d'exclusion aérienne
qui a empêché l'amusement de faire voler
ses appareils là c'est décrit dans le
détail l'obstruction par rapport à l'
enquête car voulu mener la minus me
ammoura pour documenter ce qui s'est
passé là-bas mais aussi dans d'autres
régions du du du centre mali dans ce
rapport on apprend aussi que la minus ma
opère toujours loin des caméras dans des
régions très dangereuses comme celle de
gao et tombouctou les djihadistes
renforcent leur présence pendant que les
autorités maliennes perdre du terrain
l'état malien un contrôle 15% sont à
étouars aujourd'hui 10% du nord et 21%
du centre ce sont des chiffres très très
alarmant dans le précédent rapport de la
minus ma les forces maliennes était
aussi mise en cause pour des violations
des droits de l'homme la junte militaire
s'est imposé au pouvoir par deux coups
d'état en 2020 et en 2021
ce vendredi le président nigérien
mohamed bazoum a rendu visite aux
populations du sud de la région de
tillabéri région gangréné par le tout
terrorisme il s'est exprimé devant des
habitants de la commune de makalondi à
moins de 13 kilomètres de la frontière
avec le burkina faso la petite ville
accueille depuis plusieurs milliers de
déplacés qui fuient les attaques
transfrontalières de groupes armés basés
dans le nord du burkina faso notre
correspondant harold girard nous en dit
plus
mohamed bazoum lors de son déplacement
dans le département de taureaux dit se
voulait rassurant le chef de l'état
nigérien tente de trouver des solutions
face à l'énorme pression migratoire qui
pèsent en ce moment même sur son pays
est le premier point de pression ce sont
ces dernières semaines et plusieurs
centaines de maliens qui arrivent encore
dans le nord de cette région de
tillabéri qui fuient les violences des
affrontements entre groupes armés
particulièrement celle de l'état
islamique au grand sahara le deuxième
point de pression on l'a appris il ya
seulement deux jours c'est ce que révèle
le dernier rapport de médecins sans
frontières l'algérie a expulsé depuis le
début de l'année 2022 plus de 14000
personnes vers le niger plus de la
moitié de ces personnes rapporte à
l'organisme msf des violences physiques
mohamed bazoum c'est que dans le
contexte d'une crise alimentaire très
difficile peut être la pire depuis dix
ans il ne peut tenir cette pression
indéfiniment il doit donc encourager les
déplacés internes mais aussi les
réfugiés étrangers à rentrer chez eux
dans les meilleures conditions je suis
venu ici
discuter avec vous et
créer les conditions
de retour des populations dans leurs
villages
je ne suis pas venu vous dire de
retourner
pour que je vous abandonne
n'ont jamais je ne le ferais je vais
évaluer la situation de façon détaillée
et nous ne ramènerons les populations
dans leurs villages que si nous sommes
sûrs que nous avons garanti la sécurité
quand elle sera retourné plus de 16000
personnes déplacées sont actuellement
dans le département deux taureaux dit la
menace des groupes armés restent très
présentes dans la zone rattaché à la
commune de makalondi ces deux tiers des
écoles qui restent fermés même si
mohamed bazoum veut avoir les moyens de
ses ambitions veulent et déployer et
bien l'évolution de la situation
sécuritaire ne joue pas en sa faveur
depuis le début de l'année 2022 dans la
seule région de tillabéri ses 135
incidents violents qui ont été
répertoriées contre 93 sur toute l'année
2000 21
macky sall s'est dit rassuré par sa
rencontre avec vladimir poutine le
président sénégalais qui assure la
présidence de l'union africaine et en
russie pour être évoqué les
répercussions de la guerre en ukraine
sur le continent africain écoutez le
président russe exprimé son soutien aux
africains dans leur lutte contre le
colonialisme
je souhaite vous rappeler que la russie
est toujours au côté de l'afrique et lui
apporte son soutien dans sa lutte contre
le colonialisme
nous sommes dans une nouvelle étape dans
nos relations et nous apportons une
attention particulière au développement
de ses relations
mais le président sénégalais était
surtout venu alerter sur la crise
alimentaire qui menace l'afrique car de
nombreux pays africains dépendent à plus
de 50 % des importations de blé venant
d'ukraine et de russie amine by the
sea loin
et pourtant si touchée l'afrique payent
le prix fort d'un conflit qui se déroule
sur un autre continent tous les voyants
sont au rouge car plus aucun navire ne
sort d'ukraine le pays situé à près de
2000 kilomètres des premières côtes
africaines étaient avant l'invasion
russe le troisième exportateur mondial
de blé quatrième de maïs et assurer à
lui seul 50% du commerce de graines et
d'huile de tournesol sur la planète les
routes menant au port hautement
stratégique d'odessa sont bloqués depuis
plus de trois mois l'onu craint un
ouragan de famine dans de nombreux pays
africains particulièrement dépendants
des ressources du craignent haine mais
aussi russes car les deux pays
représentent à eux seuls plus de 50 %
des importations de blé au sénégal au
liberia au bénin ou encore en mauritanie
pour atténuer les effets de cette crise
l'union africaine demande à l'europe de
réduire les sanctions infligées au
kremlin l'expulsion des banques russes
du système financier swift notamment un
pacte l'approvisionnement alimentaire de
tout le continent nous n'avons plus
accès aux eaux céréales ronaldo de ces
problèmes particuliers mais surtout
sitter un secteur agricole affaibli par
la pandémie de kobe de 19 et les
sécheresses extrêmes en 2021 la
production de céréales au sahel a baissé
de 12% par rapport à l'année précédente
selon oxfam la famine guette
particulièrement la corne de l'afrique
plus de 23 millions de personnes
souffrent de faim extrême en ethiopie en
somalie au kenya ils sont dix millions
de plus qu'en 2021
allez je vous emmène à dakar afin de
découvrir plus qu'une pièce de théâtre
une oeuvre muséal ou le musée tient le
rôle principal dans les restes suprême
qui aborde le patrimoine africain dans
point de vue original et qui a ému les
spectateurs de la biennale de dakar
retrouve en direct depuis dakar le
metteur en scène rwandais à qui on doit
cette pièce exceptionnelle dorcy rugamba
merci d'être avec nous dans le journal
de l'afrique et vous n'êtes pas seuls
vous êtes accompagné de votre comédienne
n'a ali vayrac merci à vous deux alors
dites-nous en plein débat sur les
restitutions vous avez décidé de faire
parler les objets et leur lieu de
résidence les musiques dites nous
pourquoi
avec la question est effectivement c'est
celle là on est partis de l'idée
et si les masques parler les masques
exposé dans le musée ethnographique
occidentaux qu'est-ce qui nous dirait et
c'est la fiction de départ en fait des
restes suprême qui est présenté en fait
dans une forme à la fois plastique ou
performative c'est à dire que c'est une
oeuvre qui peut se visiter sans les
acteurs mais qui peut aussi se visiter
avec une performance avec des acteurs
s'agit de quatre unités quatre
structures qui sont construites et on
soit ça raconte quelque part à la
déconstruction de ce musée en fait
d'origine coloniale d'origine coloniale
mais alors dans votre pièce il y a aussi
un parti pris celui des spectateurs
qui ont quelque part un rôle à jouer et
cela pose aussi la question de l'action
des africains les européens face à cette
question du patrimoine africain
oui ici en fait ce que j'ai voulu c'est
de confronter le public a une expérience
en fait c'est à dire c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que on est au delà du théâtre
à la rencontre des arts visuels
on peut assister à ce qui se passe
souvent de l'extérieur il s'agit presque
de quatre galeries qui sont construites
il ya des interfaces et les spectateurs
regardent dehors comme on regarderait
par le trou d'une serrure sur une vérité
cachée et quand on suit la mémoire des
masques quand on essaie de voir leur
séjour en occident au parcours qui a été
le leur on se rend compte que les
différents lieux et les différents
maîtres qu'ils ont eue raconte souvent
une histoire cachée qu'on ne trouve plus
dans les récits officiels et c'est cette
vérification à laquelle n'a voulu
vraiment confrontés les spectateurs
c'est à dire de les mettre dans un dans
une position dynamique qui peuvent
changer de perspective où ils sont pris
à partie eux-mêmes d'ailleurs par le
masque pour qu' il y ait une part active
2 de leur côté oui alors nathalie verra
qui est à côté de vous vous êtes une
comédienne comédienne dans la pièce vous
êtes guadeloupéen installé à dakar
depuis des années adoptée par les
dakarois et les sénégalais en tant que
caribéenne je me demandais quelle
résonance cette pièce avait-elle pour
vous
elle renvoie à plusieurs couches de la
mémoire se trouve c'est à dire
tout c'est tout cet espace sensible qui
a traversé l'océan qui qui nous
traversent de génération en génération
qui vient nous réveiller parfois la nuit
nous habite et nous soulever c'est à
dire il ya toute une zone je crois
immatériel où
souvent les artistes sont sensibles
peintres sculpteurs mais pas qu'eux qui
nous met en lien avec le continent
peut-être mais qui va même au delà c'est
à dire il ya quelque chose de l'ordre je
dirais de c'est peut-être ma dernière
phrase dans la pièce l'esprit demeure et
à quelque chose de cet ordre là qui au
delà de l'océan vient continuellement
réveillé en tout les cales alors oui la
personne caraïbéenne que je suis mais
surtout l'être humain la femme est
l'artiste bien sûr et alors d'or si on
se demande cette pièce qui a été jouée à
la biennale devant son succès on se
demande s'il va être jouée partout et à
quand une tournée africaine mondiale
oui c'est notre vraiment première
volonté en fait le souci même de la
montée ici à dakar c'était que pour
avoir un projet ambitieux on voulait
qu'il soit d'abord vu ici qu'ils soient
fabriqués fait part à diverses craint
prévue d'abord par les africains et nous
mettons tout en oeuvre pour que malgré
la dimension parce que c'est une
structure qui s'étale sur plus de 300
mètres carrés puissent voyager et nous
pensons la faire tourner dans toutes les
régions d'afrique au mois dont douze
pays avant de partir vers le monde en
tout cas de permettre puisque nous
parlons de l'afrique nous parlons des
africains nous parlons de leur mémoire
et de leur patrimoine
que ce soit eux d'abord les premiers
concernés les premiers spectateurs et
qu'on parte du continent et que cette
oeuvre puisse alors partir en europe
varie partir vers le continent américain
et
oui on vous entend et c'est vrai que on
invite les gens à venir évidemment avoir
cette biennale qui est exceptionnel qui
se tient en ce moment à dacca et c'est
jusqu'au 19 juin donc où résident si
vous pouvez n'hésitez pas il y a tout à
voir merci beaucoup d' or si haut comme
en bas d'être venu sur le plateau
d'avoir fait cette halte avec votre
comédienne qui est formidable nathalie
vayrac merci à vous deux tafer s'étale
sur journal de l'afrique merci
et c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis de dakar à kigali en
passant par boto rester avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]
et refi et france24 présente
le café des sports votre émission 100%
football c'est tous les vendredis débat
passionné échanges sans conditions pour
une analyse complète de l'actualité
sportive de la semaine
c'est le café des sports à vivre en
direct sur rfi est à voir sur france 5 à
[Musique]
vous allez voir et écouter le temps
qu'il fait avec écouter voir écouter
voir optique et audition mutualiste